what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
welcome to my morning smoothie thoughts
normally it's coffee but
not today so
today i'm going to be talking about
the cost of success
and
the price that sometimes like it comes
at
so right now my youtube channel has
grown stupid the last couple months so
it's grown from 50 000 subscribers a
month ago like i got 40 000 subs i think
my analytics said in the last 28 days so
that's that's stupid right that that's
that's literally stupid amount of money
i'm not about money amount of
subscribers god i'm tired
but what people don't realize like what
the cost of success is
and i'm gonna give you a couple examples
so
i i haven't
i gotten a good night's sleep and god
knows how long and i think it's aging me
and
i like was doing this 24 hour live
stream yesterday and i was so
self-conscious because
i was just like oh gosh i look so tired
and oh my god i was
but
i really i don't know the last time i
got like a good night's sleep
because and it's not even necessarily
because i don't try to it's like
i'm so excited by what i'm doing like i
love this and so a lot of times i need
to let myself go back to sleep and get a
couple more hours but my my brain is
just like ready to go and excited and i
know that's a stupid problem to have
like
well you're too excited to start your
day but
it's like it's kind of like when you
have especially that we're growing now
when you have a million things to do
like i right now i'm filming this video
i can think of like 20 things that i
have to get done i have to
figure out my budget for next month and
figure out how to do a balance sheet i
have to figure out how to form an llc
um i have to look at apartments for next
year i'm still in my master's program so
i have to figure out
um
i have to apply for my visa i have to
oh god
and i'm not trying to complain okay
because
obviously this is a good problem to have
but it's weird because you you want to
enjoy like when you're coming up and
when you're blowing up because you know
when
when when you're hot like you only get a
couple times in your career when you're
like the new kid on the block and
everyone's like eyes are on you and
that's a really cool
thing
but i'm not dumb enough to know that
like my time will come my time will go
and at some point everything's going to
plateau
and i don't know when that'll be but
but
you want to enjoy it but you're so busy
and so stressed out it's like really
really hard to
um like i just hired three people like
i'm not good at managing people
i'm renegotiating like leaving a
contract for next year you're like oh my
god anyways sorry i'm not trying to
complain because
like i love this stuff it makes me so
happy and i'm so happy that like i have
a career that i can do
the rest of my life
um but it comes at the cost and the
other cost is that
like when i started this show i just
gotten out of like a really bad breakup
so my last breakup was in december but i
was still talking to him you know like
you know when you're kind of
post breakup you're still you know
should we get back together should we
not
i don't know whenever the super bowl was
february march
so whenever that ended i was like okay i
need to
just throw myself into something because
i just want to distract myself and
i'm the type of person like when i when
i want to do something i just go all in
so i told myself for three months you're
gonna stick to a consistent schedule for
the most part i went to ireland and so i
didn't have a show but like for the most
part i i did live streams three times a
week
um and i brought people into my
apartment and i said like this is the
schedule and i just had i like knew in
my soul that if i did this for three
months something would hit like
something would blow up like i worked
too hard but i've never i wasn't working
smart before that so
i did this show
and as as i thought it would three
months in the next three months
something hit something blew up
so
alas i was correct
i was correct
so what was i talking about
oh my gosh this is what i mean i'm so
tired i'm so freaking tired um
but but but but
it came at the cost of like i feel like
i've had pretty much no dating life the
last couple of months
and
there's been a couple guys that i kind
of liked but i really haven't been able
to put in the time
into like
really fine like because it's kind of
like weird dating i don't the mana
sphere acts like
oh as a girl you have so many options
but
you have to under i'm gonna just give
you because mostly men watch my channel
so i'm gonna give you something from
like a girl's perspective and i'll give
you something from my perspective so i'm
extremely extroverted to like the 97th
percentile
so
finding someone that
i relate to is very hard not just with
men and not and not just with like it's
with women too i have a really hard time
making friends because as a youtuber i'm
very extroverted i'm very enthusiastic
and it's just like i have a very unique
personality i know the comments will
always say they'll be like oh girls
think they're special okay you can say
i'm not but i kind of built a platform
off of being unique so you know you can
you can take it or leave it like i'm not
telling you that you gotta see it so
on top of that i have a very specific
like
if you you have to find a guy you're
attracted to
and i'm tall so you find a guy that's
taller than you and you're driven you
find a guy that's more driven than you
like i know everyone's like
and i'm not saying this for sympathy men
have it way harder i'm just letting you
know our point of view like
you're looking for a very specific
person
and at times like it can be hard to find
my dad always tells me like
relationships are hard most people fail
at it so all you can do is do the best
you can that's all i do is i just do the
best i can
but
i don't know i just um
i can definitely understand like how
this comes at the cost of it
and i definitely understand like
oh my gosh
the the not wanting to run things as a
woman and that like
because i i have i i think that every i
don't want to say every successful
business woman but a lot of successful
business women have men behind them and
i'm no different i have one of them
and i tell my manager like half the
reason that i have have him is to deal
with people i don't like dealing with
people no i mean okay i love dealing
with people but not from like an
authoritative
perspective like i'm the cheerleader i'm
like the you can do it let's go
like i'm
on teams i've really i've only been the
captain like once in my life and
12 years of volleyball because i just i
don't like ordering people around i
don't like telling them what to do
i i just like
being that like enthusiastic girl that's
trying to get a bunch of [ __ ] done and
whoever wants to come with me come but i
don't like yelling at people i don't
like negotiating contracts like
and you know so
i don't know it's i'm just a weird spot
in my life
i know everyone put in my the comments
that they think that i'm high in these
videos i'm not high guys i don't drink i
don't smoke
i just have my smoothie thoughts
but anyways my point of this whole video
is that success comes at the cost of
things
so
while i am
getting more career success than i've
ever had i probably have less friends
than i've ever had
i've seen less daylight than i've ever
seen
i
am more stressed than i've ever been
and
i'm probably lonelier than i've been in
my life
which is weird because i'm surrounded by
people all the time and
that's what i mean you can't have
everything it's fine i'm happy it was a
trade-off i'm not gonna i'm not trying
to complain
but a lot of times people will compare
and it's like the thief of joy because
we'll compare to other people and you
don't
know all the time what's happening
behind the scenes so that that's my
morning smoothie thought let me know in
the comments what you think don't forget
to subscribe i love you all bye